[موسيقى]
ان التاليبان لم يختلفوا او لم ينقلبوا
على ما قالوا فانهم لم يقولوا ابدا انهم
تغيروا بل كان هناك من كان دائما
يحاول ان
يعرفهم بانهم تغيير الا وهو خليل زاد لم
نسمع من الطالبان انه قالوا انه التغيرون
بل دائما كانت هناك دعايه همم لا نعرف ما
كانت وراءها كانت بعاني وكان دائما يقول
لنا هؤلاء تغيروا يحترمونه الانسان
المدنيه وغيرها
[موسيقى]
من يوم ان دخلوا الى كابول بقوه ومعاونه
امريكيه فلم لم يفعلوا الا امنوا النسوان
والبناتنا اخواتنا من العمل من التعليم
وليس في الجامعات وليس في كليات العصريه
كما يسمونها بل حتى في مدارس دينيه
[موسيقى]
وزير التعليم العالي في منتصف نوفمبر
وبمجرد وصول
المنصب الجديد له في اول تصريح له بدا
يتهجم على جامعه الفتيات ومن ثم تهجم على
الحكومات السابقه في افغانستان وحتى على
الملوك لانهم نشروا الانحلال والفساد في
افغانستان وسبق ذلك تعيين وزير التعليم
العام في طالبان انه نحن امام مصر
ستغلق حتى المدارس الابتدائيه في
افغانستان
[موسيقى]